[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 168 of the weekly
"Google Cloud Platform" Podcast.
I'm Mark Mandel.
And this week, I'm here
with my colleague Jon Foust.
Jon, how are you doing?
JON FOUST: I'm doing great.
How about you?
MARK MANDEL: Doing all right.
GDC is over, so I'm very happy.
JON FOUST: I actually
kind of miss it.
MARK MANDEL: You miss it?
It was--
JON FOUST: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: It was a lot.
JON FOUST: Yeah, it
was my first one.
So I had a lot of fun.
MARK MANDEL: It
was pretty awesome.
It was pretty awesome.
So yeah, this week we have
Ian Buck and Kari Briski,
joining us from NVIDIA, talk to
us all about their new NVIDIA
T4s and what you can do
with them on Google Cloud.
JON FOUST: Sounds awesome.
And we will also get into
our question of the week,
specially following the new
announcement for Stadia.
So we'll give you a little bit
of more information on that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it'll be really good.
Before you do that,
why don't we get
stuck into our cool
things of the week?
We do have a lot
of gaming content.
But I do want to do what
I do pretty much always,
which is mention Kubernetes.
So congratulations to
the Kubernetes team,
they recently
released version 1.14,
which has some pretty
amazing stuff in it.
The thing that I'm
particularly excited about
is production level
support for Windows nodes.
I've been waiting for that
for a really long time.
So I'm very excited
about that, as well as
customized integration
with kubectl and all sorts
of other good things as well.
So wait for that to come
to your favorite Cloud
provider near you shortly.
JON FOUST: I can't wait.
I'm a big Windows user.
Following that, of
course, we're going
to talk about the
Stadia release.
Stadia's--
MARK MANDEL: Oh yeah,
that little thing.
JON FOUST: That
amazing new thing.
So Stadia is a new
video game platform,
delivering instant access
to your favorite games
on any type of screen.
That means TV via Chromecast,
on your laptop through Chrome,
your desktop through Chrome,
tablet or mobile phone.
And we will be launching later
this year in select countries.
And those countries
include the US, Canada, UK,
and much of Europe.
I don't know about you,
but I actually got my hands
on playing Stadia at GDC.
And it was amazing, playing
"Assassin's Creed Odyssey."
MARK MANDEL: Yeah I--
I love this, just the fact
that I don't need a console.
I don't need a PC.
I can stream the game
straight to my computer.
All I'm waiting for
is-- this is really this
I just want this experience.
Where I'm sitting in front of
my computer, and I'm like, hmm,
I think I guess I'm going to
play "Assassin's Creed Odyssey"
rather than work
on the spreadsheet.
New tab, go into Stadia,
now I'm playing the game.
[FIGHTING NOISES]
Moved on.
JON FOUST: Yeah, it's amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
JON FOUST: And it
also removes the need
for those large gaming rigs
that everybody likes to build.
I have two, personally.
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHING]
Oh, you have two.
I didn't know that.
JON FOUST: I have two.
Yeah, so imagine just
sitting in the airport
and being able to
play, you know,
your favorite
triple-A titles that
potentially may come to Stadia.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
JON FOUST: It's kind of amazing.
MARK MANDEL: I mean I
do that now in airports.
But I lug around
a 17-inch gaming
laptop that weighs a ton.
I don't want to do that.
Awesome.
All right.
So moving on, yeah, we have
a bunch of gaming stuff here.
There was a blog post
that came out recently,
talking about how Google Cloud
helped Multiplay power "Apex
Legends" and their massive,
massive, massive launch.
So if anyone's familiar with
the free-to-play shooter,
"Apex Legends," it
broke a whole bunch
of records, which is fantastic.
During the first eight
hours of its debut,
it reached up to 1
million unique players,
which is pretty amazing.
JON FOUST: That is.
MARK MANDEL: Within 70--
the first 72 hours after
its initial launch,
"Apex Legends" reached
10 million players
and has now reached 50
million unique players
after just one month.
Oh my god.
JON FOUST: Wow.
MARK MANDEL: So
this was facilitated
by Unity's Multiplay team.
They helped the "Apex
Legends" team basically
to distribute and
scale and grow this.
They have a particularly unique
hybrid scaling technology
to scale the majority
of the demand for "Apex
Legends" with Google
Cloud, but also
use its network of bare
metal data centers as well.
Yeah, they run up a lot, a
lot of Google Compute Engine
instances to make this happen.
It's pretty amazing.
So much congratulations
to "Apex Legends,"
to the team at Multiplay.
They have done an excellent job.
And we're very happy having
them on Google Cloud.
JON FOUST: Yeah.
I've actually played
"Apex Legends" just a bit.
And it's actually pretty fun.
So it's amazing learning where
the team has gone with that.
Following that,
we are announcing
that Massive
Entertainment has selected
Google Cloud as the
public cloud provider
to host the game
servers globally
for the highly anticipated
sequel for "The Division,"
"The Division 2."
The reason we've
been chosen primarily
because Google Cloud's secure,
high speed, fiber network
allows for consistent high
performance experiences
across regions.
So that supports game data
and other core services,
such as matchmaking, high
scores, stats, inventory,
and of course,
seamless gameplay.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
So yeah lots of good game
stuff, unsurprisingly,
coming out of GDC.
Why don't we go have a
chat with Ian and Kari,
and hear all about NVIDIA's T4s.
JON FOUST: I'm very excited
to talk to both Ian and Kari.
MARK MANDEL: So super excited
to be in the very fancy offices
of NVIDIA today.
JON FOUST: Super impressive.
I actually like the
color scheme a lot.
Dark colors are
definitely my thing.
MARK MANDEL: Green
and black, very nice.
We are joined today by
Ian Buck, GM and Vice
President of
Accelerated Computing,
and Kari Briski, Senior Director
of Accelerated Computing
Software Product Management.
KARI BRISKI: It's a mouthful.
MARK MANDEL: How are
you both doing today?
IAN BUCK: Great, thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
IAN BUCK: Welcome.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, thank you.
Thank you for-- special
thank you for having us.
Second of all, thank
you for joining us here
on the podcast as well.
Before we get into all the fun
and cool new NVIDIA things,
do you want to tell us a
little bit about yourselves
before we get stuck in.
Ian, you want to go first?
IAN BUCK: Yeah, sure.
I'm Ian.
I've been at NVIDIA or--
it was 18 years now.
Actually I started
very early on,
finishing my PhD at Stanford and
using GPUs for general purpose
computing, and came to NVIDIA
to actually start CUDA,
which was--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, cool.
IAN BUCK: --our first, you
know, the software programming
platform for how
people can use GPUs,
not just for playing video
games but for actually doing
more general purpose computing.
It's been an exciting ride.
And today I have a
very interesting job
of driving all of our GPUs into
data centers around the world.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
JON FOUST: I'm really
big on the gaming stuff,
so I'm real excited about
that but really interested
in learning about the computing.
KARI BRISKI: Hi,
I'm Kari Briski.
And I've been at NVIDIA
for about 2 and 1/2 years.
But I've been a leader
in product management
for about 15 years.
So really trying to focus
on that end user experience
and using our software.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Ian, you mentioned CUDA.
That's a thing.
Do you want to tell us a little
bit of the history of that,
or like just a broad overview of
what that is and what that does
and like all those things?
We have half an hour.
It's fine.
IAN BUCK: Yeah, no sure.
It's a kind of a fun story.
Back in around 2000, obviously
the video game industry
was driving a ton
of investment in PCs
and graphics accelerators
for playing video games.
As a result, those
video games were
getting more and more realistic
and more and more programmable.
Bunch of academics,
myself included,
realizing that maybe
these browsers could
be used for something
other than playing "Quake"
and "Doom" in the evening.
SPEAKER 1: I'm pinned down.
[EXPLOSION]
IAN BUCK: Which, of
course, we all were--
MARK MANDEL: Which is fine.
IAN BUCK: --we all
were doing that, too.
MARK MANDEL: Which is fine.
KARI BRISKI: Not that there's
anything wrong with that.
IAN BUCK: So we started
looking at these clusters.
And it turns out they were
like doubling in performance,
like how many floating
point operations
they can do,
literally every year
and repeatedly year over year.
And they were pretty
hard to program, just
from a general
purpose perspective,
using graphics APIs
like OpenGL and DX.
So I started a project
early on at Stanford
called Brook, which was to
explore how can we program
these things in a more
general purpose way,
in a way that exploited
their sort of natural ability
to double in performance,
to defy Moore's law,
but be usable by a general
programming audience in C
and other languages.
That was a very
successful project,
open sourced it, got it out
there, got over 10,000 users.
And then Jensen, our CEO,
invited me to come to NVIDIA
and do it for real.
So we started CUDA back in
2004, learned all those lessons
of how to do
parallel programming
kind of for the masses on a
different kind of accelerator,
a massively parallel one, a GPU.
And took it off from
there, launched in 2006,
and it instantly
became very successful
in high performance
computing and supercomputing,
and today in AI.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
On behalf of many millions
of gamers around the world,
thank you.
IAN BUCK: You're welcome.
JON FOUST: And I'm really
excited to see the big shift
towards general computing and
processing, so really excited.
IAN BUCK: What
makes it so exciting
is that it's so accessible.
You know, anyone can go
to Fry's, buy a laptop
with a GPU in it and get
access to the platform,
download it for free, and even
on their gaming PC, you know,
try it out and figure
out what they could do.
We've heard all about these
stories of PhD students
or graduate students
or even undergrads,
you know, blowing away
their peers or professors
or classmates on kind of the
stuff they can do with GPUs
that--
it was never even
imaginable when
we started this whole thing.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, Kari,
I think probably you
have a good perspective
on like, where do you
see CUDA and the things that
people are doing with GPUs,
what are the applications people
are doing with that right now?
KARI BRISKI: Oh, yeah,
like Ian said, there's
a variety of application.
But with our focus on AI, what's
kind of exciting and happening
is, the easy thing
to say is everywhere.
But if I were to sort of
break down AI applications
and what our
customers are doing,
I sort of bucket them
into three groups.
And that's like computer vision,
speech and audio, and then
machine comprehension
and [? OP. ?]
And so you can even break
those down into deeper
lower buckets of different
types of neural networks, which
we call the Cambrian Explosion.
Because almost every
task under these buckets
can be applied with
a neural network.
IAN BUCK: It's awesome to
see things evolve over time.
It all started with
that first AlexNet.
Alex Krizhevsky, a
guy up in Canada,
he was working on this
thing, which had been totally
forgotten about,
deep neural networks,
as a researcher
working with Hinton.
And you know, heard
about this thing called
CUDA, heard about
this stuff, math
that we were doing
with HPC, and realized
it was the same math that
he was doing in his research
in AI, which that back then
was still the AI winter.
He wrote the first
accelerated framework for AI
and invented AlexNet.
That's why it's called AlexNet.
It's named after And he did it
on a bunch of gaming GPUs, two
GTX 570s way back in--
I guess it was 2012.
And it all took off from there.
Today, I think we have
a massive collection
of different kinds
of neural networks,
different applications of AI.
And that's what makes it so fun.
This whole field is
constantly reinventing itself.
KARI BRISKI: Which
I think is funny,
he said, way back in 2012.
[LAUGHTER]
And it's--
MARK MANDEL: It's not
that long ago, right?
KARI BRISKI: It's
not that long ago,
and it's actually-- you know,
AlexNet's considered like a toy
now, considering the new
neural networks which are
really deep and very complex.
JON FOUST: I actually still
have my GTX 680, I think.
IAN BUCK: Oh, yeah.
JON FOUST: It's somewhere
collecting dust.
I'll probably end
up using AlexNet
and see if I can mess
around and do some things.
IAN BUCK: Yeah, we've made
things a little faster
since then.
MARK MANDEL: Just a little.
IAN BUCK: Those
first GPUs, again,
were designed for HPC computing
use cases and, of course,
video games.
But since then, we've been
constantly reinventing our GPU.
In fact, we pump through and
create new architectures,
new software stacks
literally every year
because that's how fast things
are changing in this world.
MARK MANDEL: Speaking
of new things,
I know you'll introduce
something new recently,
maybe something cool?
JON FOUST: Super awesome, yeah.
IAN BUCK: We just came out
of our GTC conference, which
is our main developer
conference, which we invite
the world to come and
we share some of things
that we've been working on.
They share the
stuff that they've
been doing on our platform,
which is really exciting.
We've been improving our
AI performance for sure.
There's two parts of AI.
There's the training part, where
we're teaching neural networks
to learn new things.
One of the things
that we've been doing
is actually making
it faster and easier
to get the peak performance
out of our GPUs.
And particularly in
frameworks like TensorFlow--
courtesy of you guys, Google,
which we work very closely
with--
getting access to
the performance that
are available in our
latest GPU core--
it's called Tensor Core, which
is a mixed-precision core that
can do things in 64-bit floating
point, 32-bit floating point,
16-bit, even 8-bit
because AI can
take advantage of all
those different precisions
and the different
layers of performance.
The new thing we announced
was TensorFlow AMP,
which is our NVIDIA
AMP acceleration
into the TensorFlow
framework to take
advantage of that
mixed precision
automatically for users.
It will automatically
pick the right precision
for the right layers
of the neural network
and maximize performance.
We're seeing huge speed-ups
This is like 2x, 3x even
for AI training.
And it's literally a
one to two-line change
in your TensorFlow script.
KARI BRISKI: Yeah, the goal was
to give a great experience out
of the box, so that the deep
learning practitioner doesn't
have to change the hardware.
They don't have to change
their hyperparameters
working in the framework that
you feel most comfortable with,
which, for a lot of
people, is TensorFlow.
We also have some solutions
for PyTorch and MXNet as well.
But AMP stands for
Automatic Mixed Precision,
which is that training technique
for being able to feature input
in FP16 and accumulate
FP32, which turns out
is really important for keeping
the accuracy of your gradients
through training.
MARK MANDEL: You said
a bunch of words there.
[LAUGHTER]
Some of them, I might
even know what they are.
Can you break that
down a little further?
KARI BRISKI: Yeah, I
think if I have, like,
three takeaways that I want you
to take away for AMP, Automatic
Mixed Precision,
is that you only
have to change two lines of code
and things just go way faster.
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
KARI BRISKI: So if you're a
deep learning practitioner
or you have training
[? on any ?] neural networks
and maybe it takes,
like, a day to train,
you can now do it in half a day.
So then you can run double the
experiments right out the box
without doing
anything different,
so that's kind of cool.
And then there is no accuracy
versus speed trade-off
for mixed-precision training.
And I want to be pretty
clear about that.
Because you say lower precision.
And yeah, you're
training in less bits--
FP16 instead of FP32.
But you're not losing
accuracy, and so I
want to be very clear
about that and have
people understand that.
And that's the third takeaway is
that Automatic Mixed Precision
training is general
purpose across a variety
of different applications.
IAN BUCK: Yeah, there's a lot of
talk about precision and using
all sorts of different
numerical formats and math.
It's really hard to get
the peak performance
and not do any compromises.
We've made that easier by
putting all that smarts,
all that intelligent, all those
numerics and complex equations
and loss functions--
more words--
[LAUGHTER]
--into a box for you.
And that was one of the
big engagements in talking
with our customers
is that they want
to get the best performance,
but they're not the ninja data
scientists.
They just want to get the best
performance out of the GPUs
that they're buying.
And we've made it a
ton easier with AMP,
and we're excited about it.
JON FOUST: So GCP and NVIDIA--
what kind of hardware are
we launching together?
IAN BUCK: GCP has
been a great partner.
You guys always want to put
the best GPUs in the cloud--
MARK MANDEL: We try.
IAN BUCK: --for your customers.
And you have since
the days of Kepler,
which has been fantastic.
We now have our Volta V100 GPUs
in the cloud with TensorCore.
AMP is specifically designed
to run those lightning fast.
And then just last year, we also
announced our T4 GPUs with GCP.
This is a little bit
different kind of GPU.
It's designed for inference,
the other side of AI.
One is training,
teaching a neural network
how to recognize things--
speech, the words I'm saying,
what's inside of an image.
That's the learning part.
Then there's the deployment
part, the scale-out,
the running of the services,
the deployment of AI.
In the past, that used to
run on whatever CPUs you had.
And typically, there
was a compromise.
You picked a small
neural network,
or maybe you couldn't
do everything.
The new AI that's coming out
now are incredibly intelligent,
very powerful, impressive--
KARI BRISKI: Complex.
IAN BUCK: They're
also very big--
lots of floating
point operations.
And this has to be real-time.
It's got to recognize
my speech as
fast as I'm talking right now,
which is probably too fast.
MARK MANDEL: You're fine.
You're good.
IAN BUCK: That's why
people are now moving
inference to acceleration.
So you guys were
the first, actually,
to launch T4 in the
cloud, congratulations.
And we've been working together
to make inference even faster
jointly with customers.
KARI BRISKI: Yeah, and just
for the audience out there,
inference is taking
that trained model
and using it for predictions.
I think a lot people use
the term predictions,
and we use the term inference.
MARK MANDEL: What kind
of speed increases
are we talking about here?
IAN BUCK: Orders of magnitude.
I mean, some stuff-- it
was not possible before.
Processing audio, doing
intelligent decision-making--
If I ask a question, I want
to have an intelligent answer
back, not just what
Wikipedia says--
or actually be able
to produce speech--
I don't think people
realize that when
computers talk back to you--
you may haven't noticed
in the last few years,
it's gotten really good.
It's really good at
sounding like a human.
That's actually because
of a new neural network
technology called WaveNets.
WaveNets actually
take in basically
a robotic-sounding
voice and output
a nice sounding
voice like you and I.
JON FOUST: Oh, I think I've
actually heard of that.
It's like you read off
roughly around 200 lines.
And it starts to
imitate your own voice
so it can read back to you.
IAN BUCK: And this
is exactly how
text-to-speech services work.
And they have a lot
of applications--
not just the home
speaker device,
but even in businesses,
in call centers,
and how we talk to computers
through automation systems.
If they sound natural, people
want to engage with them.
And it goes right to the bottom
line of an engagement score
and a SAT score for a business.
So this is one of the
new hot areas in AI.
It's one of the big demand
generators for our GPUs.
Because you just can't run
WaveNets on legacy platforms.
They're too big and
too complicated.
And they're too important
not to get right
for those kinds of services.
KARI BRISKI: Yeah, and you asked
exactly what kind of speed-ups,
and it does depend on the model.
And we call it finding
your quality of service.
So if you have these ensemble
models or an output of one
model feeds into the
input of another model,
and they all have
to be done in, like,
this enormous cosmic power
in itty-bitty living space
of latency--
and so if you add
all that latency up,
it has to have that delightful
end-user experience.
So if you speak into a
search query and then
it text-to-speech back to
you, synthesizing speech back
to you, that all has to happen
in a nice little tiny window.
MARK MANDEL: Tiny windows.
IAN BUCK: Yeah, so
latency matters.
If I'm going to
ask a question, I
can't wait a second for
an answer to come back.
I just won't use the service.
I won't use it on my
phone, the consumer.
So you have to deliver responses
in a tenth of a second.
Otherwise, after that,
the enjoyment score
starts to fall off and
people stop using it.
So we are seeing
throughputs and speed-ups
in the 10x to 100x by
moving onto GPUs, especially
for some of the new
models like WaveNets
for natural language processing,
like the new model called BERT.
MARK MANDEL: What is this?
[LAUGHTER]
IAN BUCK: Yeah, these guys
come up with great names.
I encourage anyone
listening who's actually
working on data science--
KARI BRISKI: An Ernie?
IAN BUCK: We need a Ernie.
We've got a Bert.
[LAUGHTER]
So BERT stands for--
Kari, can you do it?
KARI BRISKI: Bidirectional
Encoder Representations
in Transformers.
[SCIENCE FICTION SOUND]
MARK MANDEL: Neat,
what does that mean?
IAN BUCK: BERT is the
new neural network
that's used to understand
language, language being what
we call natural
language processing.
You give it a web page.
Please summarize that web
page-- understanding text
and contents and languages.
As I'm speaking,
understanding what I mean,
and what's the sentiment,
and summarize it.
This is very important for
things like advertising,
for search.
I need to know, is this tweet
a good tweet, a bad tweet?
Who should I share it with?
Is it positive toward
so-and-so or negative?
It's the new model
that has come up--
it's been talked about as the
grand unifying natural language
processing model that can
understand all language.
They have many different
models for different use cases.
This is the latest one.
KARI BRISKI: It's a
great multitasker.
IAN BUCK: It's huge.
It's gigantic.
But it's very intelligent
and very powerful.
It's being used already in
production today with certain
companies for doing things
like sentiment analysis,
content filtering-- is
this a safe thing to share,
not a safe thing to share--
a very important part of AI
today and one of the driving
forces for moving AI to GPUs.
JON FOUST: Our listeners
obviously can't see me,
but I have this huge
grin on my face.
So many light bulbs are
going off in my mind
right now for future projects.
And this sounds
completely awesome.
So curious--
availability for the T4?
IAN BUCK: It's available
today, so people
can rent it right now from GCP.
So if you're an
on-prem customer,
you get it-- also
available on servers.
We're available everywhere.
Our mission is to
make our technology
available through every channel.
The cloud is a great time
to market, especially GCP.
So we're excited
that you guys are
leaning in and getting our
latest technology out there.
We also make our
software available.
So we do a huge amount of
work, and people don't always
understand this, to
accelerate the frameworks--
the AI frameworks
like TensorFlow--
or the rest of the
inference software
stacks, so that
users of the cloud
can very quickly
deploy these models
or build services on top of it.
We publish optimized framework
containers about every month
now across the board--
TensorFlow but also PyTorch
and MXNet and the other guys.
We also publish a bunch of
our inference software, which
Kari can explain more, to allow
customers to just not have
to build AI from scratch but
start from standard building
blocks.
And all that runs on GCP
right out of the gate.
KARI BRISKI: Yeah,
so when Ian-- you
said that T4 has a little bit
of everything for everyone.
The FP64, it's got FP32.
You get FP16.
You get [INAUDIBLE].
But our software is built
in so that you can actually
flip a switch and exploit
these features like Tensor
Cores inside the hardware.
And I want to say the FP16 is
a great format for inference.
I mentioned earlier that
we had this mixed precision
for training, but
you don't actually
have to have that
for inference either.
You can literally
just flip a switch
and know that you'll get
the same sort of accuracy.
With INT8, there is a little
bit more consideration
that has to be taken in
both with your training
and quantization of these
weights and activations.
But you do get benefits
of memory space and power
limitations when
you actually take it
to this reduced precision.
And we offer software
that can do that for you.
And one thing that we did
is this software framework
called TensorRT, and we've
integrated it into TensorFlow.
So it's a lot of
tensors going on.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: It's all
right, you had GTC.
We're GCP.
It's all fine.
[LAUGHTER]
KARI BRISKI: Yeah, exactly.
So what we've done is we've
taken that software that
takes the best advantage
of optimizations
and put it right
into where people
do most of their work,
which is TensorFlow.
IAN BUCK: And then we
push all this software
on the web free to
download as containers.
They can pull from--
MARK MANDEL: I assume
like Docker containers,
and it's all standard?
IAN BUCK: It's all standard.
It's all in Docker containers.
And in fact, we also have
examples of all the models.
So they don't need to
download separate models
from everywhere.
It's all captured in the
containers as a straight up
building block to fire up and
run and create a service built
on these things.
So if you want the latest BERT
that's been optimized for GPUs
or the latest ResNet 50
or whatever have you,
feel free to come to NVIDIA.com.
They're on-- it's
actually NGC.NVIDIA.com.
You can download all
those bits and pieces.
They all are qualified
and run on GCP.
We even have some
HPC stuff on there.
There's some base
CUDA containers,
if you want to actually get
your hands dirty and program
GPUs directly.
All that software
is freely available
and maintained and ready
to run on GCP's cloud.
Again, the URL is--
MARK MANDEL: We'll put a link in
the show notes, make that easy.
Saying URLs out loud is
complicated and hard.
KARI BRISKI: Yes.
IAN BUCK: You know, we're
seeing that shift from on-prem
to the cloud
conversation happening
in all sorts of places, not
just obviously in the AI world,
but also in the traditional
computing space.
The high-performance
computing guys,
the people doing simulations for
drug discovery or understanding
astrophysics and how
galaxies and stars--
we do a lot of that work too.
And actually, all
that can be done also
on the same GPUs in the cloud.
So some of the
research community,
the higher-ed guys, people
doing science and discovery
can take advantage of
these GPUs as well.
JON FOUST: That's awesome.
MARK MANDEL: No, that's
very interesting.
And now I'm actually
kind of curious.
You brought the
on-prem discussion in,
which is always interesting.
Where do you see people using
the cloud versus on-prem
and the trade-offs therein?
And what helps people make
those sort of decisions
for using GPUs on
servers, essentially?
IAN BUCK: A lot of
this new AI technology
is being invented in the cloud.
That's what makes
it so exciting.
And what I love about the
cloud is the accessibility.
You just can get access right
away and to try it, to use it.
It's a few bucks an hour
or even cents an hour
to get access to a GPU and
start using GPUs for AI or CUDA
or whatever.
You don't have to
go through the IT.
We do see trade-offs
at the larger scale.
Business decisions--
what makes sense
to keep on-prem versus
push in the cloud?
Some of that's economics for
sure, but others, you know,
security or whether
or not they just
want to maintain that
as their own enclave
that they can control
because it's really
important for their businesses.
From our standpoint,
we're agnostic.
My job is to make our
technology available through all
the channels.
And I certainly like
working with GCP
because I know
how aggressive you
guys are at bringing the
latest technology to the cloud.
KARI BRISKI: Yeah,
one of the big deals
for on-prem versus cloud
and some of the work
that we've done is with
the Kubernetes community,
so making sure that GPUs
were first-class citizens
and something that's
completely vanilla to the work
that you're doing.
So you can have your Kubernetes
cluster deployment on-prem,
and then you can burst to the
cloud with the same settings.
We've done a lot of
work there with being
able to make sure that
it's pumping out metrics
of GPU utilization,
power metrics,
you know, how are you--
that system administrator,
what is the health of my system
and how do GPUs fit into that?
We want to make it as
vanilla as possible.
We don't want GPUs to be viewed
as this unique and beautiful
snowflake-- which they are.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: Of
course, they're lovely.
Don't get them wrong.
KARI BRISKI: I did want to bring
up a little bit the inference
server.
You kind of have these three
basic blocks when you're
working through AI deployments.
You have the
preprocessing of the data,
you have the training, and then
maybe if you're really expert,
you have this optimization
and then deployment.
And I hate to use something as
mundane as DevOps for something
as exciting as AI, but
that's kind of what it is.
And I think some people
who might get scared about,
where do I begin with
AI model development--
you just take that same
practice and approach to it.
And we have tools at every step
along the way for every person,
whether you are
data preprocessing,
if you're a deep learning
data scientist and researcher,
if you're the software developer
who is trying to integrate
the model into that
application, and then
the system administrator
who's trying
to take care of all
this stuff and keep
the health of their environment.
IAN BUCK: Yeah, so
you can see we're
pretty active at all layers
of that software stack,
not just the cutting edge of
the actual development, new AI
usage, but all the
way down the system
management and monitoring.
And like Kari said, all
the excitement around
Kubernetes-- we're definitely
in there working very closely
with that community to make
sure that it's all GPU-ready.
The other area
that's hot right now
is the traditional
machine learning.
We talk a lot about AI,
but a lot of that math--
it's reinvigorating
data science.
There's a lot of
algorithms out there
that actually are well proven
and very successful for doing
predictive analytics
that are with more
traditional linear
regressions, k-mean clustering,
gradient boosting
decision trees.
We've also started to
accelerate those workloads.
It's the similar kind
of math and operations
that we were doing before.
We've integrated with Google on
some of your Cloud ML pipeline
workflows to accelerate
some of the algorithms
people are deploying for
traditional predictive
analytics.
Particularly, gradient boosting
decision trees, or XGBoost,
comes up a lot in
forecasting, wanting
to know when I'm going to
go out of stock of bananas
and I need to ship more bananas.
There's point-of-sale data
for every retail store
all around the world.
And data scientists
are drowning in data.
They just lack the
compute to actually make
those kinds of predictions
and often in the time windows
that matter, which can
be literally just hours.
So we're starting to see
much more acceleration
of traditional machine learning.
We have a software
stack called RAPIDS,
which is bringing some of
those algorithms-- collection
of algorithms-- and
GPU-ifying them,
making them available
to people to integrate
into their predictive
analytics platforms.
Particularly, we've
been working with Google
on accelerating those as well.
And that's some of
the stuff that we've
been talking about here at GTC.
And it's exciting to see not
just deep learning but all
of machine learning recognize
the opportunity that GPUs
can bring to accelerating
all those kinds
of predictive workloads.
JON FOUST: Where
would developers,
data scientists,
anybody who wants
to use these interesting
things go to get started?
KARI BRISKI: Everywhere.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: That
narrows it down nicely.
KARI BRISKI: No, honestly,
like Ian said earlier,
the easiest place
is NGC.NVIDIA.com.
We have a lot of containers.
We have examples.
We have models and scripts
of exactly the recipes
that we have applied
to get the best
performance to the state
of the art accuracy for all
of these models.
Like Ian said before,
we work really
hard to put this into
open-source software
as much as possible.
So if you're using a
GCP VM, we actually
stay in contact with
the VM team to make sure
that they're getting the
latest optimizations that we've
contributed to TensorFlow so
that they're working perfectly
on our latest GPUs.
IAN BUCK: We've also been
providing educational services
as well. so our GTC conference,
we host many hackathons.
We host many tutorials.
We have our own Deep Learning
Institute, which we call DLI.
Frequently,
customers come to us,
and they want to
just learn about AI.
So we have a program where
anyone can come and sign up
and we'll run a Deep Learning
Institute at their company.
We'll show them how to
use the latest containers.
We'll show them how to configure
their GPUs to get them started.
They'll actually train a
neural network, go use it.
And by doing the canonical
use case of a toy use case,
they can then turn around and
go back into their companies
and go from being just
a DevOps person or just
a traditional data scientist
to being an AI expert
and figure out how to apply
these things to their business
use cases.
We're very active in
that community of people,
obviously working with
many customers that
want to get started on GPUs,
want to get started in AI,
just don't know how.
We see it our mission to
help educate and help.
KARI BRISKI: And I know
we said it earlier,
but the product
manager in me really
cares about the end
user and their persona
and what they're trying
to do with their job.
And so if you're a
system administrator,
you can feel good about our
contributions to Kubernetes
and check out our [INAUDIBLE]
center GPU management
utilities.
And again, all of this
is on NGC.NVIDIA.com.
If you're a deep
learning practitioner,
definitely check out AMP.
Again, that's in the
framework that you use most
to take advantage of
mixed precision training.
We've also made available
Kubeflow Pipelines, so
examples directly into the
Kubeflow Pipeline repository
across a variety
of applications.
We're entering one
for medical imaging.
We're entering one for
intelligent video analytics,
for transfer learning.
And then we're also doing, like,
the "Hello world" with ResNet
50 and deploying that on an
inference server with Kubeflow
Pipelines into Kubernetes.
And then if you're
the software developer
who really doesn't know anything
about deep learning models--
you just know that you have
to put it into your software
application to get this, you
know, say, yeah, I'm using AI--
definitely check our
inference server that's
also open-source software.
MARK MANDEL: One of my
favorite questions to ask--
what's been the most interesting
or potentially weird or wacky
thing that you've seen people
do with AI or NVIDIA chips?
KARI BRISKI: Well,
it's kind of wacky,
but one thing that's
gotten a lot of notice
lately is the celebrity
face synthesis.
It's gotten a lot of
press and attention.
And I think there is even a site
that you can click on and try
and guess which face is real.
That's been kind of
the neat one lately.
IAN BUCK: I've seen
my face plastered
on a few people, which is
very interesting to watch.
MARK MANDEL: It's fine.
IAN BUCK: There are all
sorts of applications of AI
that I've seen.
I think some of the coolest ones
are actually in agriculture.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, interesting.
IAN BUCK: People don't
think about it that much.
But I believe there's a
cow with a Fitbit on it,
and they're trying
to figure out the--
MARK MANDEL: Getting
your steps in?
IAN BUCK: Yeah, trying to
figure out the health of cows,
improve milk output,
understand when cows are sick,
using AI to understand herds--
very cool stuff.
There's actually interesting
work in strawberry picking.
I didn't know this, but
apparently strawberry fields
need to be picked
every three days.
So it's not a crop
you grow and pick it.
You have to constantly
be picking it,
and it's an area that is
actually very labor-intensive.
And obviously, it's hard
to find all this farm
labor that can constantly come
and pick it for three days.
So there's all this cool
stuff in robotics right now.
There's a strawberry
picker that's
being developed with GPUs
that has a little articulating
arm and a camera.
And so it's actually
a really hard problem.
You've got to figure out
and do segment analysis.
Which pixels are
which strawberries,
even if they overlap?
And what's the ideal place
to grab the stem and cut it?
You never want to actually
touch the strawberry
because that would actually
potentially transfer
funguses or molds and
that kind of stuff.
MARK MANDEL: And you don't
want to squish strawberries.
IAN BUCK: You don't
want to squish them,
and you've got to do
it every three days.
So there's some really cool
stuff happening in robotics.
And that, I think, is some
of the next-generation stuff
that we're going to
start seeing coming out
of AI, just very convincing,
very compelling, very
interesting robotics
applications that are going
to make our lives a lot easier.
JON FOUST: Being a
gamer, I do happen
to have RTX 2080--
just curious to see
if we can see that
same technology that
is being introduced in RTX
within the GPUs that are going
to be in data centers?
IAN BUCK: Yeah, one
thing we've always done
is we made our technology
available on all of our GPUs.
And that's made us so
successful is the fact
that anyone can get access
to the latest NVIDIA tech,
even if they're a gamer.
Because many of the
people actually inventing
the next-generation stuff,
whether it be science or AI,
they're probably gamers too.
So with RTX actually, all
the Tensor Core capabilities
are there, available.
We're already starting
to put it into games.
And in fact, there's work
being done for a final frame
rendering.
So the very end of a
frame-- of a rendering
of a frame of a game-- we
actually can apply AI to it
to improve its visual quality.
We actually spent a lot of work
training the neural network
to improve the image quality.
We actually render it in
much higher resolution
and then downscale
and teach an AI
how to do automatic
color correction,
to eliminate jaggies,
to do anti-aliasing
using AI on every frame.
That's like millions of
pixels 60 times a second.
We actually do a
full neural network
on every one of those
pixels to actually improve
it to do a final pass for
AA improvement on your GPU.
It's a really hard thing.
I mean, that's real real-time.
JON FOUST: I could imagine.
IAN BUCK: That's why I think AI
is going to affect and impact
and improve every one
of the applications
with GPUs in every industry,
not just agriculture
but gaming, automation,
robotics, the cloud.
It's super exciting.
MARK MANDEL: We are running
out of time just a little bit.
But before we go,
is there anything
that you want to make sure
that the listeners hear about
or you want to plug, any
events you're going to be at,
or any new content that's
been delivered recently
that you want to make
sure people are aware of?
KARI BRISKI: Yeah, so I think
a lot of our biggest event
has already passed.
But you can always
visit our booth
or come see us when we're at
all the top AI conferences.
Some examples are
ICML, ICLR, CVPR.
There's a lot of acronyms
here, but if you know them,
they're speaking to you.
IAN BUCK: We're also attending
more of the obviously
DevOps and cloud conferences.
We'll be at Google
Cloud Next, and we'll
be at KubeCon and other places.
So reach out.
Feel free to contact NVIDIA.
Again, we're working
on all of the stacks
and the applications, so
please don't hesitate.
JON FOUST: Well, that's
going to wrap it up for us.
We will really,
really enjoy this.
Light bulbs are still going off.
Once again, I would like to
thank you guys for joining us
on the GCP Podcast.
KARI BRISKI: Yeah, thank you.
IAN BUCK: Thank you, bye.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks
again to Ian and Kari
for joining us on the
podcast and telling us
all the amazing things that are
happening with the NVIDIA T4s.
But also, thank you so much to
the NVIDIA team for hosting us
at the NVIDIA office.
It is a gorgeous office if
you ever get down that way.
JON FOUST: It is super
amazing, and I am a big fan
of dark, tinted glass.
So it is amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome, yeah,
so thanks so much for that.
So before we wrap up,
question of the week.
I know you've been digging
into this a little bit, Jon.
JON FOUST: Just a bit.
MARK MANDEL: So if people
are interested in Stadia
and they want to
learn more, either as
a potential consumer or
a potential developer,
where can those people go?
JON FOUST: So the best place
to go would be stadia.dev.
It's the new landing
page for Stadia.
There you can find all
the general information
that you need.
And if you would like to
sign up for developer access,
the best place to go
is stadia.dev/apply.
MARK MANDEL: Well, Jon,
where are you going to be?
What are you doing?
What's going on?
You doing anything special?
JON FOUST: Maybe a
couple special things.
I'm going to be at Cloud
Next in a couple of weeks.
I will also be at ECGC--
[GUITAR RIFF]
--in mid-April.
And I will also
be at Vector 2019,
which will be very amazing.
I have also jumped on board
to be at I/O this year.
So this will be great
because it's my first I/O.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, fun.
JON FOUST: And I
will potentially
be at Unite Shanghai--
[DRAMATIC MUSIC]
--which would be a
great experience.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, congratulations
on working out what
you're doing post-I/O.
[LAUGHTER]
So yeah, I will be at
Cloud Next as well.
I will be hanging out at
the GCP Podcast booth.
So definitely if people
are going to be at Next,
come by the GCP Podcast booth.
Myself will be there.
Jon will be there.
JON FOUST: I will.
MARK MANDEL: A variety of hosts
that we have will be there.
Gabi will be there,
et cetera, et cetera.
So definitely come by.
We'll be doing some
recording on the show floor
and doing live episodes,
all the usual good stuff.
I will also be at East Coast
Game Conference just like Jon,
and then I will also
be at I/O as well.
I/O is pretty exciting.
We'll tell you more about
that as we get a bit closer.
JON FOUST: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Jon, thanks so much for joining
me yet again on the podcast
this week.
JON FOUST: It's
always a pleasure.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful, and
thank you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC]
Thanks again to Ian
and Kari for joining us
and also allowing us to
have a wonderful visit
at the [STUTTERS] NVIDIA?
JON FOUST: NVIDIA.
MARK MANDEL: NVIDIA.